Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
the Keptn project. We have done an episode
in this previously where we looked at using
Keptn for a continuous delivery with some really
cool cracks in the site that help gate
and protect your deployments from errors and bugs.
Today, I'm gonna be joined by Juergen once
more. Juergen is an engineer at Dynatrace and
a maintainer of the Keptn project. Hello, Juergen.
Welcome back.
Hi, everyone. Thanks. Thanks, David. I just gotta
say, I love your Keptn t shirt. It's
really cool. Yeah.
Thanks.
It's our very famous logo. We're we're happy.
Nice.
Do you wanna kick us off with just
a short introduction about yourself and then we
can start to talk about the Captain projects
again and do a little summary on where
we left off last time.
Sure,
thank you.
So my name is Jurgen. I'm one of
the Keptn maintainers.
I think we've started this project around two
years ago.
It was originating
from more an idea of how we can
make continuous delivery and operating software better. It
was
that the whole idea was about automating
a lot of steps and then we first
found, we built kind of a methodology
and then we from this we built a
whole Keptn project. So it's been around for
some time. It was initially started by Dynatrace.
It's now a open source CNCF
project.
We are in the sandbox phase of the
CNCF.
And yeah, in the beginning I was also
one of the main developers.
Right now, I'm more taking a look at
the Keptn ecosystem, how we can integrate with
other tools.
We just built the Litmus integration
recently.
We're building a Locust integration. We have other
integrations for different
testing tools, automation tools, deployment tools. So this
is what what what I care about these
days.
Pretty excited.
Okay,
awesome. Yeah, I think what I realized last
time when we were looking at this project
is that it really is like the one
complete tool for implementing continuous delivery. There was
a lot of different components, a lot of
different features that we can you know, adopt
and leverage inside of our Kubernetes environment.
And we only got halfway through the tutorial.
So today
we're gonna try and take a look at
the rest of that tutorial and the other
features that Keptn brings to the table. So
I believe you've got a few slides that
you wanna run through to introduce us to
Keptn again and give us a quick summary
of where we left off.
Cool. Yes.
So I just want to share a little
bit of
let me just, am I already in presenting
mode? I'm not sure. I think now I
am. Yep, there you go.
Okay, perfect.
So I just want to give you again
a brief overview of Keptn and what we
did already last time and what we are
going to see today.
So it's Keptn itself is the cloud native
application lifecycle orchestration.
So you can, that basically means Keptn will
orchestrate
your existing toolset for
deployment,
for testing, for evaluating
or you can do this just with Keptn.
There are different use cases that users,
when users start with Keptn they go either
full Keptn
with having
progressive delivery with Keptn, having quality gates with
Keptn, doing auto remediation with Keptn or they
go only for one part. For example, Keptn
quality gates. That's one of the aspects of
Keptn that we see that's frequently
used and heavily used because it's a very
mature concept of quality description of a microservice
and or can even be a monolithic application
and then Keptn will evaluate
based on different data sources like Prometheus evaluate
the quality of the software and can make
a decision if it should pass the stage,
if it should be promoted to production or
not, for example.
It's all built on declarative
configurations.
So it's very much in all the Kubernetes
space. It consists of basically YAML definitions
and you can connect different tools to it.
I already said what you can do with
it.
You can automate a lot of parts like
monitoring,
how do you want to do your delivery,
how you want to have your remediation executed.
And this is done
event driven or data driven. So we are
using cloud events for this and cloud events
are sent to Keptn and from Keptn and
then you can interact with these different tools
or go different tools
can interact with Keptn based on the cloud
event standard, which is also a CCF project.
Last time,
I think we already covered the part why
we did it. It's a lot of, the
main part is really automation and making your
continuous delivery more robust and also giving you
guidance and framework for automated remediations.
And last time we already did a couple
of the first two use cases. So we
took a look at how to automatically
configure
observability and dashboarding tools. We were using last
time already Prometheus.
We will do this also today.
We've been using
two major concepts and two major files of
Keptn. The first one is the environment definition.
We call it the shipyard file.
And I am from Austria. We speak German
here. Captain for us sounds like the captain
of a ship. So it's really we have
a shipyard file. We have a captain's uniform
which defines the tooling that you need or
that you want to use.
We have a
lot of things in captain. We have the
captain's bridge, for example, which is our UI.
A lot of things they have like this
nautical terms and then this idea behind it.
Our tagline still is nobody ships apps like
the captain. So
it's yeah. We we we like this theme.
So the shipyard file is basically describing
your environment. And
just with a couple of lines, can describe
a multistage
environment and this multistage environment basically also reflects
a multistage delivery pipeline.
Between the stages, Keptn automatically executes a quality
gate. And this quality gate can be based
on SLOs
as we can also see here. But these
SLOs, service level objectives,
can also be used for configuring
and setting up your alerting and your dashboarding
and your observability tools. So for example, we
can use these SLOs
configure the Prometheus alert manager,
to set up Grafana,
and also have alerts in Grafana and just
general
setup the scrape jobs rules.
Also, what we can do with this SLO
file, as I already said, it's the definition
for our multistage delivery. So with this SLO
file and with this shipyard file,
we have a multistage delivery definition
already with a quality gate and Keptn will
execute this quality gate and will trigger the
quality gate
whenever we want to move from one stage
to the other stage.
And if you want to do a direct
deployment or a blue green deployment, it's just
a matter of the configurations in
the Shipyard file.
We will see a little bit of this
also in today's presentation. We saw this also
last time. We went in more detail last
time. I know that David has already prepared
a couple of things for today so we
can kind of
have
everything that we did last time which is
continuous. So we will see a little bit
of this also and I will just explaining
as we go through it.
The new part that we will see
is actually
more in the remediation part. But just as
a reminder how Keptn quality gates is is
working,
We are based on two concepts
coming more or less from the SRE community.
So if you're familiar with the SRE book
from Google or if you're interested in this
book, it's a great book. And they are
promoting two concepts
there. The one is the SLIs and which
is for service level indicator
and service level objective short SLO.
These are the one of the major concepts
there.
So the first one is basically an indicator
is something like a metric. You can think
of a metric.
So
in Keptn you can define,
I would call it a library or a
list of indicators and you map the name
of the indicator to a PromQL.
So then you can reuse
the name of the indicator in your SLO
file and the SLO file defines an objective
for an indicator. So for example, the error
rate has to stay lower or equal to
1%. So in this case we can easily
define the error rate and in the SLO
file we do not define where the data
is coming from. So whenever we want to
change how we retrieve the data, maybe we
want to change from one tool to the
other, maybe
we just have to clarify
the granularity of the data. We can do
this in the indicator file. We don't have
to change our quality gate definition.
And it's not that we only care about
one
objective and one SLI but we can
mix and match different
SLIs.
We can have absolute thresholds, we can have
relative thresholds
that will be then compared to previous runs.
For example, the number of database calls is
allowed to increase by 2% to the previous
runs
but it also should stay within 10
database calls per transaction.
So there are different ways to define this
quality gate.
And whenever it's triggered
by
either by external tool or within the Keptn
continuous delivery
workflow,
here it is just an example to to
trigger it with the Keptn CLI,
then Keptn will reach out to the different
observability tools and data providers,
will query
all this data based on the service level
indicators
and will then
score the service level indicators.
Each time it's a full pass of the
criteria, you will get a full point. If
it's not a full pass but it's still
inside a warning criteria,
you will get half the points and then
in total, Keptn will come up with a
score.
And this score you can then use to
decide if it should be promoted to the
next stage, if you want to keep it
in this stage, if you want to roll
it back.
This is then if you're just using Keptn
quality gates, it's totally up to you. If
you're using Keptn,
I would say like the full installation of
Keptn, Keptn can then automatically
initiate a rollback, for example, of
this deployment.
And we can also use the same file
to configure our alerting and then react on
our
problems or alerts that are coming in.
So an alert, for example, sent from the
Prometheus Alert Manager
can be then consumed by Keptn. And if
there's some remediation actions defined and added to
Keptn, Keptn can trigger this evaluation these remediation
actions can again evaluate
if the action was actually successful
based again on the SLO file and then
either execute the next action or close
the issue.
So we'll we'll see this also in today's
demo.
For example, we have an alert coming in
from Prometheus.
Captain will first take a look if there
is a remediation action defined
for this service that is affected
in a particular stage or environment,
like preproduction,
production,
whatever.
Keptn l and, again, if you might remember
from last time, Keptn is based on a
on on on a git approach, so all
the configuration files are stored in its internal
git repository or on GitHub or GitLab or
Bitbucket wherever
you want to use it.
And it will store its configuration files in
this git repository. So it will also take
a look in the git repository if there
is some kind of remediation configuration.
If it can find this file, it it
will go ahead and trigger the remediation action.
So for in this case, it will scale
up by
an increment of plus one which could also
be like plus 10% or whatever you want
to call it.
It will reevaluate
the quality gate based on the SLO definition.
It will then,
if it cannot meet the required
quality, the criteria,
then it will go ahead and execute the
second remediation action. In this case, it's a
feature toggle.
It will again reevaluate
the SLO and then it can escalate or
close the issue just based on the outcome.
So this is actually what we're going to
look at today. I think we will start
maybe with the Quality Gates since we already
have an up and running working environment.
Am not going into the architecture right now.
Maybe if we have time in between, I
can always come back to this and show
a little bit of the architecture.
But
if it is fine, we just
deep dive already into into the the hands
on part.
Nice. Excellent.
Cool. So now
we let's get my screen up then. So
what I wanna do is just go over
what I prepared in advance to make sure
that we're on the same page there. I
really hope I've not messed up which is
you know, only happened nine out of 10
times on this show. So
screen.
And we also have a hello comment. Hey,
Philip from Berlin.
Thanks for joining us.
So
Hi, Philip. I just
my calendar just chilling there. Don't know why.
So I've worked through the tutorial which is
available from the Keptn
website.
I've completed up to step 14, which is
roughly where we got to last time. Think
what we agreed was
on the previous episode, we did do the
quality gates, but there's some value and got
over that again quickly.
What we have is a Kubernetes just
must remember to clear my screen before I
do this stuff. What we have is a
Kubernetes cluster
with the captain workloads.
There we go. And we have our application
workloads
and their own namespace.
Is that stock shop? Right?
Yes.
I believe we have two different
or even three namespaces,
stock shop dev production staging. So that's also
one thing.
So Keptn is in the current version.
We are
kind of making the distinction
between environments by namespace.
We are already working on this, making this
distinction between environments also per cluster. So in
the future with the next release of Keptn,
it will be possible to have a multi
cluster setup and move have a dedicated, let's
say, staging cluster and a dedicated production cluster.
Right now, it's separated by namespaces.
Nice. I think that would be a very
welcomed addition. I think from the the people
that I speak to there there's
a lot of growing support for the multi
cluster setup definitely. So that's nice to hear.
Okay. So
how do we
Oh yeah. And this repository, the captain repository
is available online. This is what we're continuously
writing to when we make changes
and
we have the Captain's Bridge available too.
So
what we want to do now is to
just correct me if I'm wrong here, Jochen.
But we're gonna trigger a deployment with the
quality gates to show that stopping a build
being promoted from one environment to the other.
Is that correct?
Yes. So
in your preparation also in the last episode
what we already did was
deploying
in multi stage environment deploying the
shopping cart of our Sockshop application.
So we were deploying this. It went through
dev staging all the way through production.
And
now we
are adding
SLO files, quality gate definition file and we
trigger another build or actually and we we
trigger another deployment with already pre built image
and we will see how Keptn will prevent
it moving to production.
Okay. That sounds good. So
let me see if I can remember. I
think I did
this Prometheus
step.
So this is does a captain ad resource
where it adds the SLIs that we have
to find in this PremiFuse file.
Should we pop that open or we move
on to the next step? What do you
think is best?
We can execute it again just to make
sure that we have added this file.
I think it's already
uploaded.
We can actually take a look into the
git repository.
The screen is a little bit blurry on
my end so I'm not sure if I
can, if I'm a bit behind
but
in the git repository
we should see in the staging branch
we should see
in there will be a Prometheus folder and
all the configuration files that are responsible for
Prometheus should be there and we should be
able to see the SLI definition. If it's
not there, we just execute this command and
Keptn will upload
Prometheus SLI configuration into the Prometheus folder.
Okay. And we have the Prometheus SLI dot
YAML, so I think we are okay.
Yeah. All good here. So that's basically the
definition how to query different
metrics
from Prometheus.
In this case, it's all
about the response time but you could add
error rate, throughput, memory consumption, CPU saturation, whatever
you want to add here
with your
PromptQL
or Keptn comes with a couple of predefined
metrics that you could also reuse. In this
case we're just making it clear how the
concept of SLI is actually working. So we
just define our own SLI putting it into
our git repository.
Okay. Alright.
Let's move on to the adding our first
quality gate then. So what we're gonna do
here is add
another resource and this time it's the SLO
quality gates.
We can actually see the contents of this
file here. Let me zoom in on that.
I'm still seeing the
GitHub
screen. So maybe it's a little bit lagging
on my side here. Oh, no. But
if you're already on the SLO part, that's
perfectly fine. I I what what I will
do is I will just
have my tutorial
also next to me so I can just
follow
along and just
Okay. Well, I was just there for now.
I'm gonna add the resource.
So not found that's because,
am I in the correct directory?
There we go.
So we're now added to resource that has
this SLO file.
Let's see if I can work out what
this is doing. So it adds a it's
got a comparison key, which has an aggregate
function. I compare with an include the result
and a number of comparison results. Do you
wanna maybe just tell us roughly what this
SLO is doing?
Yeah, sure.
So it's basically the definition of the quality
gate
defining
how we want to evaluate it and how
we want to compare it. So we are
comparing to the previous
result,
just a single result
and we're only comparing it to previous results
that passed.
So if we have a quality gate that
failed and another one is also failing and
we're just comparing it to the previous failing
one and we have, for example, relative thresholds,
we would not get really good numbers because
we would
compare a failing error rate to another failing
error rate and we would maybe allow it
to pass. So we in this error, in
this quality gate, we only want to compare
it to previously passed
results.
And for
if we are using more than one result
we would do the aggregate function. We would
just do an average. So we are not
taking the minimum or maximum of the error
rate of previous runs but we would take
the average. So if it's only one
actually we don't actually need the aggregate function
but in this case we are doing the
aggregate average.
And then we have a couple of objectives
and these objectives are defined on
SLIs.
And
actually in this case we only have one
SLI which is the response time in the
ninety fifth percentile.
It's defined in the SLI file that we
just, that David just showed you.
And here it says key SLI is false.
That means
if a key SLI is true then the
Keptn Quality Gate fails if only this one
single
evaluation fails. So if you have 50 SLIs,
but one is very crucial,
that would be a key SLI
or five are very crucial. Otherwise,
they all weighted with the same
weight. You can also change this with the
weight
key here.
And then we have the pass warning criteria
with the combination of relative and absolute thresholds.
So it's allowed to pass
if it's
faster than six hundred milliseconds and if the
increase to the previous
run that also passed is below than 10%.
So this is how we can build quality
gates and we can do this with,
yeah,
combining absolute values with relative values and thresholds.
So that that's pretty cool.
Perfect.
So we've already added that to our cluster.
Now we can verify the current versions of
dev station on production and see what we're
actually working with here. So
let me just grab this command.
And this should give us a URL
which we could copy.
So we can see our dev version here
running 011.1
and it's green. We can change this to
staging
and
production.
What was it? Prod?
Probably it's prod. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, no. I'm
just failing to type. So that's a pretty
common occurrence. Alright.
Where did I get wrong? Production?
We'll Oh, it is production. It's production. Oh,
sorry.
Let me just run this command just in
case then.
Oh, it's a different IP address. Okay.
Nothing coming up coming up here? No. I've
broken production.
Okay. So it's actually it's just not it's
not deployed. Maybe we can take a look
if we can find the pods.
Yeah. Let's do that. So let's get namespaces.
Let's set our namespace to stock shop production
and make sure we've got our pods running.
We've only got the DB. We don't have
the cars.
Yeah. So what we can do is we
just start another deployment. We already have the
quality gates up and running which is totally
fine
and
once we do the
another deployment actually it says here that we
got a failing quality gate.
Can we take a look at the staging
here? So it was not moved to production
because the quality gate was failing so actually
we have to prove that the quality gate
is already working.
So it's not the Quality Gate that we
set up right now but it's actually I
assume the Quality Gate that you set up
yesterday for the preparation for today. So
we can take a look at
the carts.
Probably clicking on the quality gate here will
give us a little bit more detail.
So so just to clarify there, the problem
is is that Keptn is too good, and
it detected a problem and stopped our promotion
to production. Production. So I like that.
Kind of. Kind of. Yeah.
So we did not get any
let me just get the the light here.
So it says the response time was actually
failing here.
So it was probably
too slow to
or the response time was
not satisfying.
So let us just do another deployment
probably with the same version. Maybe there was
some
maybe there was too much traffic on the
cluster
or it was not coming up.
Yeah. So there was a command for that.
Right. This one here. Captain send
event new artifact,
pass through the tag. So I could just
run this to deploy the Yes. Same version.
Alright. Yeah. Cool.
And what it does is basically it's sending
a cloud event to captain. So building a
cloud event and sending this cloud event to
the Captain control plane
and it tells Captain there is a new
image
of
our service carts
of our project Sock Shop. So that's the
project Sockshop and the service carts was previously
onboarded to Keptn.
David has done this in the preparation and
also in the last episode you can see
this and
we just
informed Keptn now that there is a new
container image which has the version 0.11.1
it's actually the same we want to deploy
this one.
Based on the shipyard file with the multi
stage delivery
defined,
Keptn will start to deploy it first in
in the first stage of this delivery file.
And in our case it's called dev. So
it starts to
the Helm charts,
release version
in our dev environment. We'll then apply this
Helm chart. It will also
apply this, the changes to the Git repository.
In this case it might take a
couple of seconds
since it also waits if the deployment is
actually finished, the basically a Helm upgrade if
it's finished And our
I think it's the the readiness probe takes
about thirty seconds,
fifty seconds, something like this to for for
the pod to be ready. So it just
takes a couple of seconds
and then Keptn will tell you it's finished
upgrading the chart and it's already deployed in
the first version or in the in the
first environment. Yeah. So I think it's deployed
to dev now. So is is there a
way for us to follow this from the
from the bridge? Do we see that
rollout happening?
Yes.
We can take a look here in
services.
So we have the environment we can see
all the different stages but in services we
can see all the different services that we
have already onboarded
and we could see for example yesterday there
was
Quality Gate was failing
and we can see the
current run,
the last configuration changed.
So configuration changed here means we changed
either the image or we changed load distribution.
We see the configuration was changed. We see
it was deployed.
We can see a quality gate screen in-depth
but this one was actually green because we
have not added any quality gate in-depth.
So it was allowed to pass And we
can already see here in staging
there is an approval.
There are a couple of approval events
but we set the approval
to automatically.
So whenever there is a quality gate
which is
if there is no quality gate or the
quality gate is passing, there will be an
automatic approval. So for between dev and staging,
we just allow it to pass basically
and now it says there it changed the
configuration so it's basically triggering the deployment. The
next event will be
once the deployment is finished
And once the deployment is finished, Keptn will
trigger the tests.
That's right now I have to admit the
small hiccup in the Keptn's bridge because it's
not indicating
that right now tests are executed.
So
also in the last episode what we've done
is we have added some JMeter tests and
also here JMeter tests are added and they
are automatically
triggered by Keptn.
Again with the same approach Keptn will take
a look if there
is a in this case a JMeta folder
in our staging branch of our carts microservice
then it will take a look on the
files in this folder and based on a
mapping definition it will then execute these files.
So right now tests are executed.
They might take about two minutes to finish.
They are I think 5,000 requests are sent
to some
endpoint of our shopping cart
and once the tests are finished Jmeter will
send back CloudEvent to the captain control plane
informing captain tests are now finished please go
ahead with the next phase whatever the next
phase is and the next phase is our
evaluation.
So we can see tests are finished
for the evaluation.
We
we are doing we we're retrieving data from
Prometheus so we can see data retrieval,
and we could see it's not.
It seems to
it's not working. Yeah. It's it's failing. So
let us take a look at the response
time p 95 at at at the icon.
There was a a red icon that should
give us a little bit of indication why
it's failing.
Yes. Here.
So
Needs Prometheus.
Could not connect to Prometheus service.
Okay. Let's take a look if we have
Prometheus deployed.
So there should be
Uh-oh.
Okay. There is no Prometheus here.
So no no worry.
What we can do is
we can configure Prometheus
with Keptn and
actually I think in step number 13 there
is some Prometheus
information. So we are
here
in,
again, in this version of Keptn, we are
Keptn is managing the Prometheus installation. So with
the first
with this command, we are
adding the Prometheus service to Keptn, which is
also responsible for configuring the Prometheus.
And with It does say it's all unchanged.
Exactly.
So that seems interesting. But Prometheus itself is
might not be running. So there is another
command
for
Keptn configure Prometheus.
And this one we need that's also setting
up
setting up Prometheus, setting up the alert manager,
setting up the SLO, setting up the
scrape jobs
all based on the SLI file, the SLO
file, and the
shipyard file.
So now we should be able to see
those pods up and running.
Here we go.
I'm
I'm still confused by that because when I
applied this, it says unchanged which means this
deployment already existed
but we didn't have any pods.
So does that deployment scale it with a
replica of zero and then as this kept
in configure command that scales up?
Is that right?
Not not exactly.
Can we take a look in Keptn namespace
on all the pods?
Because
the
we can see here is also Prometheus installed.
Mhmm.
And
the way it works is
if we I will explain it on the
Prometheus SLI service.
So the Prometheus SLI service you can install
it into the Keptn namespace. It's the one
component that is responsible
reaching out to a Prometheus,
fetching the metrics
and providing it in a way that Captain
Quality Gates can work with these metrics.
The Prometheus SLI service is living in the
Captain namespace.
Same is true for the
responsible to reach out to Prometheus
and configure this Prometheus instance.
So those have not been changed and
those have been running in the Captain namespace
since
eighteen hours.
But Prometheus itself
was not yet started.
It's only triggered when you do a Keptn
Configure
Monitoring and then you can provide the name
of a different monitoring solutions.
Keptn Configure Monitoring Prometheus
will then kick off send a cloud event
to the Prometheus service which will forward it
to Prometheus.
So only with this you will start actually
the Prometheus.
Okay.
So
let me let me summarize what you just
said there because I I feel you're being
too polite and what you're actually saying is
David you had one job and you fucked
it up like that's that's essentially what you're
saying.
So
we don't have Prometheus.
We would just you just missed one command.
But it's it's it's not it's not a
problem. So what what we want to do
is we just send exact we just trigger
the pipeline once again. Awesome.
And hopefully,
this time, we will fetch the correct metrics.
Yes. So now that we have But it's
great to see how it failed.
Yeah yeah, you know, it's nice seeing
the the bridge and showing you how
this failed and then even getting that error
to say, oh we had no previous like
we didn't actually really have to debug anything
there, we just had to go all this,
we don't have what we expect. I missed
the command, we run the command and now
we should see this work through properly Hopefully
this time.
Nice. Yeah. We give it a try. Yeah.
It'll be fine. I've got confidence.
We have another hello from Mark. Hey Mark.
Hope you're enjoying your week off.
Hi Mark.
So
I guess now this is gonna take another
two two minutes roughly to run through the
entire pipeline.
Yes.
Okay. Most
of the time is is spent on the
actual deployment and then the the execution of
the tests.
In dev, it's not a lot of tests.
We just ping if there is something
if the endpoint is available in staging.
We do a little bit
we we execute
a little bit more but it should come
up just in a second.
Alright. Thanks.
And then what we're doing next is to
deploy
a rather broken version. So zero eleven two
which should fail our quality checks one more
time. Is that right? Yes.
Exactly.
What we can do there is
this version should not make it to production.
So this version we will see it in-depth.
We should also see it for a couple
of minutes in staging.
In staging, we are using
a blue green deployment. So we're first moving
it to staging.
Maybe just wait for this, we will wait
for this to finish.
Also the same is true here. We are
moving the
one version.
Right now it's the same version but we
are moving one version as a blue or
green version into staging.
We are executing the tests against this version
and then we are executing and triggering the
Kept quality
based on the outcome. We keep quality gate
is fine. We keep this version. Otherwise, we
roll it back to the previous version.
If we keep this version, Keptn will also
tell the next stage to start deploying
or actually trigger the approval process in the
next stage.
Yeah. So
production, it's we should not it's not yet
there because Yeah. We have to wait for
the tests. Yeah. And then we should see
that rule in our entire production namespace.
So this is now running.
Okay. So this is done the auto approval
to staging. We have to wait for staging
to finish and then the Gmeter test will
be kicked off.
Exactly.
And for this automated approval,
yeah, deployment finished so now the tests will
be executed.
For this approval that's also quite nice. Here
we have it automated just for the sake
of the demo that we don't have to
click here and wait.
But
our friends from Citrix, they have built an
integration to Keptn with a Slackbot.
So whenever there's an open approval, they get
this message directly into Slack
and can click either accept or reject
and they will also get
all the data from the quality
evaluation from the previous stage. So they will
see what is the quality of the service
and then based on this, they can make
the decision and they are they don't have
to leave Slack. They just work in Slack.
You could have the same in Microsoft Teams,
I guess, but
Whatever you're using.
All of the above to be honest. So
yeah, that I can see there's a lot
of value in that. I know, you know,
getting those kind of information and no, we're
all using Slack these days, right? It's we
spend a lot of our time there communicating
with our colleagues have not under them. So
it's it's nice that it has that integration
and we can see the performers results and
improve it directly from Slack. I can see
a lot of value there.
It passed. Way.
Oh yeah.
And now I have to Oh no, the
approval is finished.
So we should There we go. We now
have production pods.
Finally.
Yep. And then if I come over here,
not quite yet.
I guess there'll be probes on that. So
the service would be passing in the end
points yet. So we just have to wait
a little bit longer.
Describe service
cars.
Yeah. No end points yet. So we'll just
wait.
Patience is not my virtue half the time.
I will be honest.
Like I don't want quality gates just deploy
everything to prod as soon as it's ready.
My customers are quality gates.
No. That's a terrible attitude. I shouldn't promote
that advice. That's terrible advice.
Yeah. Sometimes
for
sometimes you you just want to deploy something.
We actually what what we see with with
feature flags it's the same that you have
the feature flags. You cannot test all the
combination of your feature flags in the pre
prod or hardening, staging, whatever you call it.
So it's basically your customers are
your testers and
this is one of the ideas that we
also built into Keptn with
combining feature. We can
we now have integration for example to the
Unleash feature flagging framework that where we can
just reach out to it and toggle a
feature flag if there's something
not not working.
In our case, everything's working in production. That's
cool.
So then we have to break it.
Right? Is that that's what we're doing? Just
Yep. We can just exactly. So
now we are deploying a rather slow version
of our shopping cart.
Again it's
so
once you're using Keptn it's,
there is some initial setup
with creating the project,
with
onboarding the services,
with adding your test information, with adding your
quality gates and all the SLI information, how
to retrieve the data from Prometheus or
Dynatrace or Datadog, New Relic, whatever you want
to use.
And then most of the time you're using
a Keptn add resource
to rewrite your quality gates or to add
more
test instructions
or you just use Keptn send event new
artifact which
basically tells Keptn to kick off a new
delivery workflow.
We also have integrations
in
I think it's Azure DevOps where we just
one
one guy from the Keptn
community
with the name of Bert Van Dyke. He's
from The Netherlands and
or from Belgium. I'm not yet sure. But
what he what he did is he was
building an integration into Azure DevOps
where the whole Quality Gate part is Keptn
and the whole other part with the delivery
is Azure DevOps. So you can think of
this that you can just use parts of
Keptn in your existing
environment if you already have have it.
Yeah. I think what's really cool about this
is that, you know,
more and more organizations and teams are trying
to codify their SRE initiatives,
you know, codify their SLIs and their SLOs
and that's what what Captain is doing here
like, we have this YAML syntax that's
hopefully intuitive
and easy for people to pick up and
then commit that to get and then have
all of these checks built around that automated
for them. Such a powerful set of tools.
Let's see what's happened here. We've
got our evaluation
is now gone to staging. So we're just
maybe a minute out then.
And what we should see is we've already
seen it twice because of my little mistake,
but
a promotion to production
being blocked by the quality gate. So
I guess we'll have this time what we'll
see instead of an error message that just
says, you know, I can't speak to Prometheus
is that we'll actually see the
response time fail of the
required values.
What we should already see is
how it's deployed
into dev, you know, into our dev environment.
So if you can open up the dev
environment
again,
we should already see the yeah. That's kind
of the broken version indicated by the red
background,
kind of,
yeah, obvious.
In staging, it should also be deployed
already.
I think it says in the in the
bridge that it was deployed, but not sure.
Not yet. Okay. No. So
Yeah. So it's it's approved at end staging,
but it's not actually
deployed just yet.
It's about to be deployed,
but traffic has not been shifted yet to
the to the new version. It We will
get the information here in the bridge once
traffic is shifted and deployment has finished.
Then we will be able to see this
version also in the browser
and it will be there. I can already
spoil a little bit here. It will be
there for a couple of minutes while the
tests are running. And after the tests,
we will have another evaluation of the Keptn
Quality Gate.
And so here we are. And
the captain quality gate, if it's failing, it
will roll it back to version number one,
to the green version.
If it's not failing, the captain quality gate,
then we will keep this version here and
we will move it also to production. So
hopefully, we don't move this version to production.
It's
kind of the slow version.
Unfortunately,
this will take a couple of minutes because
it's the slow version, the tests we send
about 5,000 requests against the service. So the
requests will take more time and it will
take about, in my experience, about like five
to ten minutes.
I guess we can just move on. Yeah,
we can talk about our next steps. We
don't have to execute it already
but this is what we will see. It
will not be promoted to the next stage
because of the blocking quality gate.
And again
in the demo, the quality gate is very,
very simple. We just care about the response
time in this demo. But again you can
build your quality gates
having all different kinds of
metrics and data in it.
For example,
most often you want to care about the
error rate. So you want to make sure
that errors are below, I don't know, 2%
or not increasing
by more than 5% to the previous runs.
You want to make sure that throughput is
high. You want to make sure that response
time is low. So all of these things
you can build in your Keptn quality gates
and
if you don't know the exact values yet
then we see a lot of Keptn customers
or Keptn users actually.
They are
using relative values.
So they are using just,
let's say, response time is not allowed to
increase by 10%.
Throughput is not allowed to decrease by 10%
to the previous runs or 5%.
So you can build your relative thresholds and
once you have
you know what your absolute threshold should be,
then you can fill it in or improve
your quality gates or however you want to
do this. Okay. Can I ask a question?
I'm over waiting. So
assume
we know that that's broken and you know,
maybe we're just adopting Keptn and we are
you know, the the automation is really cool,
but at the same time, we're still checking
the metrics ourselves manually during the place. Like
what happens if I trigger this new artifact
now while we're still in the middle of
another
currently processing deployment? Does it get queued up
afterwards? Does it start the roll out to
dev just now? What would go on there?
So in the current version of Keptn, this
is actually a problem
because it, you would just kick off another
workflow.
It will move it to dev and it
will also move it to
staging. So right now there is no blocking
mechanism.
This is also what we're going to fix
in the next version.
The reason why it
was built like this is that
actually
most of the time the artifacts are coming
out from some kind of CI system.
And
after the CI system you decide, is it
a version that I really want to deploy
into dev or staging or whatever? Is Is
it the version that I already want to
deploy or was it just like
a test build? And once you decide you
want to deploy this version,
there should be kind of a
blocking mechanism that you cannot deploy anything into
staging whereas currently
deployments going on or tests going on but
in this version you would, it would not
be blocked by Keptn.
So in the current version.
Okay.
So do you see, like going back to
the Currently we are using Keptn in a
a multi namespace approach. So we have a
namespace for dev, namespace for staging and a
namespace for production.
But you also said that, you know, in
the next version we can expect to be
able to have a dev cluster, staging cluster,
a production cluster. Do you see Captain as
something that runs on like a management control
plane cluster outside of those other clusters or
with
Captain running my dev cluster and then promote
to other clusters? Like, what do you think
the ideal setup would be there?
That's a good question. I think it really
depends on the use case where we also
see that Keptn is just running on the
Keys,
K3S
on the Keys installation
where you just run the Keptn control plane
on
a small Kubernetes distribution. You don't want to
run a full Kubernetes cluster because you're only
using parts of Keptn. So you run it
on a small Kubernetes distribution. If you're going
full Keptn,
then you might want to run it on
a stable environment, maybe not in the dev
environment because
if it's one that you tear down and
recreate a couple of times, you don't want
to have to install Keptn all the time
again.
So that might be living
production related
cluster,
the Keptn control plane. And then you still
have Keptn services
running on different clusters because they have to
be able to execute some actions on these
clusters.
Can Keptn run as a control plane run
outside of Kubernetes? Could I just run it
as a daemon process on Linux or does
it does it require those Kubernetes APIs to
be available?
It's not so much about the yeah,
it's a little bit about the Kubernetes APIs.
It's just built in a way that we
need some kind of service discovery, we need
some kind of this orchestration.
So you can run it on a smaller
Kubernetes distribution
but
it's built in a way that there has
to be some Kubernetes runtime
below Keptn. Yeah. I think that's a really
good idea actually, like you mentioned,
maybe using like a single node KCS cluster
running a captain there as a control plane
and speaking to other you know federated clusters
in some fashion. That would probably be a
really good pattern I think for this kind
of thing.
This is what we've seen with captain users
also having this the quarter gates
with
more monolithic applications.
So they are, they just want to do
quality gate check every now and then
or regularly.
And they are not running yet on Kubernetes.
So they just want to do this with
in a
install Keptn on a VM with k3s
and then trigger a Keptn via the API
or via the CLI.
No need to go full Kubernetes if you
are not yet ready
and you don't have to re architecture your
application if you just want to use parts
of Keptn like the Quality Gates.
You have to have some kind of monitoring
because you need some data
for the Quality Gates to evaluate
but
we don't actually
there are no restrictions where the data can
come from. Right now we have integrations with
a couple of tools.
It's open source so everyone
is is more than welcome to provide more
integrations with more tools.
Excellent.
So we're sitting around eight minutes. I'm expecting
us to fail
any second now.
Our staging is
red.
And this is this just takes longer because
of that
arbitrary injected latency which affects the 5,000
test runs.
Exactly.
So we're gonna be moving So the next
part, yeah, we can actually deploy the regular
cards version. We can actually skip this part.
Why we can skip it is
if the Keptn quality gate is working correctly
and I'm pretty positive that it will,
then we will not move the broken version
into production. And for our final part of
the stream, we will do the self healing
part and we will take a look at
how,
actually I want to call it auto remediation.
It's not self healing in a way that
will fix your code but it will
remediate actual issue.
So it's,
in the next part,
we can use the version that's already running
in production, in our production namespace,
because
version number three and version number one, it's
actually the same version just with a different
background. There is no latency introduced. There is
no
nothing else introduced.
The only thing what it
what both versions can do
is first they have a feature flag implemented
with Unleash so we can change from outside.
We can change the configuration
and we can react on this
that Captain can reach out again to unleash
to the feature toggle framework and turn off
a feature flag that we turn on.
In this tutorial, we do it a little
bit differently. We will be just adding
a couple of
other items to our shopping cart that will
incur
the
decrease
of no, an increase of the response time
and we'll just initiate a scale up. So
you can do this with also with auto
scaling of of
but we are doing this with
with with Keptn
so that we also have all the configuration
of how many replicas are actually running. We
also have this versioned
and stored in our git repository. Repository. This
is one of the reasons.
Hopefully,
by now, the tests have already been finished.
I'm actually
not sure. Yep.
Looks good. So let's take a look at
the quality gate evaluation.
Yep. Okay. It says the
response time is way too high. It's more
than one second.
And so tests were running for eight minutes
and thirty eight seconds. Response time is failing.
We we don't have the error rate here
but
we I I did this
couple of test runs I did it before
and the error rate is always stable close
to zero. So it's not about errors. It's
really about the response time. We can also
see it's already rolled back to the previous
version. Yep. And if we go to
production,
we can take a look also in production.
It should still be
also version number one running, but it's the
version number one from previously, from from a
couple of minutes ago. Yep. Cool. It's healthy.
So the next step then is we're gonna
add our
new resource. And this time, we have a
self healing
SLI resource.
Yes. So this is just
as as I said, we can have different
ways how to retrieve our service level indicators
and this one is prepared for
to retrieve the the right
response times for the
for the self healing use case. So this
just is
you can have it
we're just overriding this actually or we are
adding this to our production
environment
Because
in our previous runs in production we never
did the quality check. We only did the
quality check-in staging
and then if the quality was good in
staging we moved it to production. In production
we are not executing any tests. As David
said we have our end users doing the
tests in production so we are not executing
more load or JMEDA tests in production.
What we also want to do is this
time we are adding an SLO file, so
a service level objective
in production that says if we execute a
quality gate in production
it has to satisfy this criteria
and
now that we want to also,
yeah we should see it here, It's actually
very similar.
We also see the SLO file here just
added sixteen seconds ago.
Very similar to the previous one.
And what we also want to do is
we want to do another Keptn Configure Monitoring
because now that we have SLOs and SLIs
in production,
we can also configure Prometheus to the
Prometheus
alert manager
to use production. So we actually create alerts
for our production environment.
Here it says Prometheus successfully configured. Rule created.
And
what is the next step? Now it's getting
blurry again. Oh, the remediation instructions.
Yes. So we're adding
let's should we take a look at that
file, I guess?
Yeah. We can take a look.
Remediation.
It's
basically a very simple instruction here.
It's the remediation file looks very much like
a custom resource definition.
It's not really a custom resource definition. It's
just a YAML.
It's a clear description for Keptn how to
do remediations.
And it has a list of problem types
and whenever this problem type is coming in
via CloudEvent,
Keptn will execute all these actions that are
counter actions for this problem type
and execute one,
evaluate the Quality Gate again, execute another.
In this case we have
the same actions for different types of problems.
The one is just called Response time degradation.
That would be
actually the problem type that's coming in from
a commercial monitoring solution called Dynatrace.
For
this tutorial we could use the same file.
The
problem type would be called response time degradation.
In Prometheus,
the problem type is called response time p90.
That's just how we set it up because
the Keptn integration
between Prometheus
and
and and Keptn,
it's using the SLO
or
yeah. It it it's using the the the
name of the
SLOs
for the problem type and it's kind of
inverting
the SLO and whenever the SLO is then
breached,
it will
kick off the alerting in the alert
manager.
And the action here is to scale,
scale up by a value of one. So
that's what we should see.
That means we should see a replica set
of two when everything's fine.
Now we want to generate some
load to cause that remediation step to be
executed.
Exactly.
So this version,
all three versions actually, they have some faulty
item
in it and
we can just add,
we will apply a load generator that will
add all those
faulty items into a shopping cart that will
slow it down quite drastically
And then we should be able to see
that in that the response time is degrading
and Keptn will kick off the the response
time of the
Okay. So right now we have one
one pod running for our cats d b,
our cars d b. So
if we apply this load generator, we should
see
that increase.
Yes. So
this will
take a while.
We can take a look in Prometheus how
this affects
our response time.
Does that have a special name, or is
it just
There there is one query that we provide
that you can just take, and it it
gives you the the the exact graph. Yeah.
This one. Oh, good. I thought I was
gonna have to remember PromQL there. Okay. Yeah.
It's always giving me a hard time.
Alright. So hopefully, we something. Yeah. Oh, look
at that. There we go. We have a
space. Okay. Yeah. It's already increasing.
Let's just jump down to five minutes. Yep.
One minute. Yep. There it goes.
So
yeah. Or is this gonna look similar to
that?
Yeah. We can watch the self healing in
action.
And we can take a look. We should
see already that there is an alerting rule
set up in the alert manager. So this
is what we can take a look at
also in Prometheus.
Yes.
And what
does it say here? Yeah, unfortunately,
in our demo
it says it has to
break this rule for ten minutes. So it's
only after ten minutes. It's
not great for these kind of demos. So
we actually have to decrease this time. Otherwise,
it's not really useful if we have to
wait ten minutes all the time for
to kick in.
But what will happen after ten minutes is
that
there will be an alert sent from Prometheus
to the Prometheus integration in Keptn, which will
translate this alert into a cloud event.
And this cloud event is then forwarded to
Keptn.
Keptn will forward it to the remediation service.
This is also a little bit the part
where we need Kubernetes because Keptn itself consists
of a couple of different services.
So it will forward it to the remediation
service.
And
we have different as you see in the
remediation
YAML,
there are different actions that you can define.
And one action is scaling. So there we
have a specific component
that can remediate
scaling issues or that can execute the scaling
action.
Yeah, exactly here. So the action is scaling.
And as we're also doing deployment with Helm,
we will also do the scaling with Helm.
We will rewrite the value of the replica
set in the Helm chart and then use
Helm again to
deploy this.
And we will also see it in
the git repository of Keptn that this value
will be changed.
So we will
scale this version or scale the replica set.
We also have other integrations, for example, for
the feature flags
that I mentioned earlier. So for the feature
flags,
we have the integration of Unleash which will
then use or which will retrieve the information
from Keptn,
will
translate this into an API call for Unleash
and would turn off or turn on a
feature flag.
Yes. So we have a couple of integrations
here.
One that we have the
does it say here the unleash?
I I don't see unleash. No. I don't
think it's listed on this page.
Oh, we missed it.
We have to add it here.
But we have, for example, the I just
saw it. Yeah. Keptn unleash.
Self healing.
This is for the previous release,
but we we can see that it's here
working.
We
can also see how how it works here.
There's actually also we did a webinar kind
of with the with our friends from Unleash
even. So
glad that they they have not bugged us
yet that we forgot to to to list
their integration. We we can see the remediation
objects here. So, you know, action is feature
toggle, and then the the value of the
toggles are turned on or off. So nice
and self explanatory, you know, pretty intuitive.
Yeah.
Yeah. So there there are different tools that
you can integrate.
Unleash is the one that's,
yeah, pretty pretty
good
and it's working great for
the feature flags. It's really a great framework.
It's also open source by the way.
And
the
because you you just had the integrations page
up here,
one of the last integrations that we did
was together with Litmus,
which is also one part that I really
like.
Litmus Chaos is a chaos engineering
engine
built on Kubernetes
and the cloud native technologies.
And the
really cool thing here is that
usually
when we talk about executing tests we talk
about functional tests or performance tests, load tests,
but what we built with Litmus or how
we combined Litmus is then whenever we enter
a testing stage in Keptn we don't want
to execute only performance and we don't want
to just trigger some and hit our services
with some load.
But we also want to introduce chaos to
our services because you might know that in
production
it's not always everything is not always sunny
weather in production, let's say like this. So
there might be some problems in production
and we can already simulate these problems in
shifting left and doing this in previous phases.
So
by introducing either a chaos stage in Keptn
or just doing it in a preproduction stage,
adding the Litmo service, you can execute
chaos for example removing a pod or introducing
network latency
while you also have some performance tests running.
And once both are finished you can use
Keptn quality gates again or Keptn will trigger
automatically the quality gates And then you evaluate
the quality of a service while it was
under heavy heavy load and while it was
under chaos
testing.
And with this, you can you can evaluate
what is actually the resilience of my of
my application.
We we just had in the in the
Keptn user group,
we had Adrian who is an SRE
at
the in building exactly this use case and
evaluating the resiliency by either having no chaos,
light chaos, or heavy chaos.
And they
requirement to the application is that no chaos
and light chaos
have to basically behave the same which I
think it's
pretty interesting that they say our application it
has to be resilient in a way that
introducing light chaos to application should not change
anything to our quality gates.
We have to be able to survive some
light chaos by just removing one part of
a replica set or by introducing network latency
of a couple of microseconds that has to
survive,
which is pretty interesting.
Yeah. I think litmus chaos is is one
of those things that I keep me into
play with and I haven't got around to
yet. But, you know, now that you've described
the concept of heavy chaos, I feel like
I'm gonna have to deploy that to all
of my environments now to see how things
to see how things weather that storm
and I love that you can integrate that
with Keptn as well to kind of build
in those remediations and stuff like that. So
it's cool.
So there's
quite a few integrations here then so I
mean that's cool. The Slack one, the ServiceNow,
we got notifications
of course is Dynatrace
as a whole tower. Lots of stuff for
people to experiment and
what's involved in writing an integration. See, I
think, oh, I actually I wanna build like
maybe Discord notifications or Twitter or whatever. Yeah.
Some of that. What's involved in writing one
of those integrations for Keptn?
We usually recommend to get started with the
the the Keptn
service template.
We call our integrations a service also. It's
a service to it's a Keptn service. And
we provide a service template in Go. We
might also provide it with other programming language.
But since Keptn Core is written in Go,
we also provided the first template in Go.
You can use this template and basically what
you have to do is there are a
couple of event handlers.
And you define in
the deployment file of
your service, you define
which events you're interested in. I explained in
the beginning, Keptn is event based and data
driven. So there are a couple of different
events like deployment
finished event, test start event, test finished event,
configuration changed event, remediation start event. So there
are a couple of events and whatever events
you're interested in because
on the example of the Litmus service, we
are interested in test start events because then
we want to start
tests and we will send a test finished
event so the captain knows chaos tests have
been finished.
If you are in
a deployment tool that you would react on
different
events. If you're like a Discord service
might want to listen to all the events
because it might just want to notify notifying
in on Discord about everything that's going on
similar to the captain's bridge, for example. So
you basically decide where you want to to
which events you want to subscribe.
And then you will go ahead and implement
in the different event handlers. You just implement
your logic.
And depending on the integration, you might want
to send an event back to Keptn or
you you don't want to. It just depends.
For a notification service, you usually don't send
an event back to Keptn
that
you sent the notification. It's not like, okay,
you did it, great. But for a test
integration,
it's important that you inform Keptn that tests
have been triggered and tests have been finished.
So,
and
we provide this, the whole template here.
It already has the all the event handlers,
which are just, it's basically just a stop
where you just write your your business logic.
And
most or the the first part where where
we ask the Keptn community to to provide
their integrations is the Keptn sandbox.
This is where we start developing new integrations.
We can already see
we can see the Monaco service. We can
see the local service. I just initiated
some
discussions in our Keptn Slack. It doesn't have
any resources right now here, but we found
a couple of folks that are interested in
working together on the locus service and we
will define what it has to do,
how we want it to behave.
I heard there are different ways to execute
locus tests. One is via the CLI, the
one is via the API.
So we would just kind of discuss how
we want to build it and
this is the first place to put it.
And once they are
used and tested,
then we can move it to Captain Contrip,
which is the place where also the Captain
Core community is more also more involved in
maintaining the integrations.
Yeah. I think
Alexa notification service. I've just had an idea
for like my next Friday hackathon project, which
is to have my feeling my feeling quality
gates turn the room color red, I think,
or maybe green on a pass. So I
know where my deployments have broken. So like
some sort of Philips Hue integration to change
my legs. I think that would be good
fun.
That would be cool. That would be so
cool.
Yeah. I would love to see them. Yeah.
I I would've worked on that for sure
definitely.
Alright. Let's see where we are with our
query here. I still have that in my
buffer. I do.
Let's graph that over ten minutes.
Okay. I do it my way.
Alright. We're almost there. I think we're just
we're approaching the ten minute So what we
should see
is if we
run
I'm in the wrong direction.
If I run get pods,
this should start to scale up. Oh, it
has. Oh, yeah. We've got two of them
now a minute ago. So
Oh, already did. Cool.
Yeah. So Nine nine seconds ago. Yeah.
So is there a visual way of that
in the bridge? Will I see this
anywhere? Okay. So it's also here in the
sequence screen.
So we can see that there is a
problem opened. We can see everything that was
going on. So it's actually a couple of
events that are sent through Keptn. It's first
a problem open event coming in, a remediation
triggered, the remediation status changed, an action has
been triggered, action has been started. So it's
a lot of things again where
subscribe to it. You can add your services
to where we can see which services are
responsible. For the actual action,
I explained earlier that the action itself, the
scaling action is done by the Helm service.
If you have your own scaling or if
you want to,
I don't know, increase the
brightness of your hue lights in your room,
whenever time there is a scaling you could
also listen to this scaling events in your
service.
And it says action started, action finished. So
already
we know that it already did the scaling
and in Kubernetes we already saw that there
are now two pods.
Excellent. If it's not yet
remediating
the response time that it will evaluate again
the Keptn quality gate and if it needs
another scale up to meet again the quality
gate of Keptn, it will do another scale
up. So it's just you
can start small
like let's say you don't have to scale
up by 100% but maybe just by 5%
and then if it's already meeting the SLOs
again, it's fine. If not, then it will
execute it
another time
or you can execute another action. So you
can as I've shown in the in the
slides, you can mix and match the the
remediation actions.
Cool. Awesome.
So we've already seen this work.
We've seen it in the bridge
and
I guess if we leave that wrong long
enough, we'll see the response time
drop.
Yeah. And we should also see that the
the alert is will be
be closed again. So first the alert is
pending. They will be firing and then it
will be will be going away and go
back to green.
But it takes a while for us to
see everything. So
I think the the most important part here
was that we saw it how the remediation
is actually kicked off
and which files are included. Everything is again
based on the definition files, the declarative definition
files of Keptn based on the shipyard file.
SLO file is a very strong concept and
one of the most important files in Keptn
as it defines the quality gates.
SLI file defines how to query all the
data that's needed for the quality gates.
Remunation, the file defines which actions are kicked
off whenever there's some alerts coming in or
a problem coming into Keptn.
Excellent.
I
think we've covered an awful lot and I
think we've seen a lot of really valuable
use cases for what Keptn can offer for,
you know, Kubernetes this deployments. I think
you know, the the quality gates are just
so valuable for anyone who wants to ship
anything through multiple stages and then being able
to build your own event driven remediation loops.
Think it's just wildly cool as well. I'm
assuming any integration that I want to build
or access to all of those events embedded
by any other plug in within the captain
system. Is that right? So I
just say, hey, I want to listen for
this and I want to start all I
mean it was other stuff on top of
it. I think just the power and that
event driven kind of loop
opens up so many different possibilities for the
way that we deploy our applications to Kubernetes.
So very very cool. I'm very excited about
that.
Is there anything else? Yeah. It's it's really
exciting. Sorry. On your go. We are yep.
I I can just oh, sorry.
Okay. So
we are really excited also to share
soon our next iteration of the shipyard files.
The file that we saw or maybe if
you could scroll up here on this screen
a little bit on the first part I
think we saw the shipyard file.
And yes,
so this was the file that we are
also using
in the demo or in the tutorial.
If you want to walk through the tutorial,
it's tutorials. Captain. Sh.
But we got
some requests from the Keptn community and we
are in the next iteration
are we're doing an
yeah. A
new iteration and an improved version of the
shipyard file.
And we already have the Keptn zero dot
eight alpha out there
and I'm pretty sure that we we can
deliver the
stable and final release of 0.8
pretty soon and it will be even more
mature and there will be more use cases
possible. Also they have parallel stages to have
multi cluster support. So there's a lot of
things
to come.
Also by the end of this week hopefully
we will be releasing a new version of
the Keptn website.
So it's a we are in exciting times
with this project. And if you can think
of any integrations that you want to see
or you want to start,
please also reach out to us on slack.captain.sh
because we are happy to provide you the
git repository
in the Keptn sandbox so it's kind of
the place where your integration is also visible
and you can provide it to the Keptn
community.
If you want to start on your own
repo, we can always merge it later.
But we're
always happy to see new integrations also in
this organization
so that it can be shared by everyone.
Awesome.
So yeah, everyone join the the Keptn Slack.
Start writing your own integrations. I'm gonna start
my Q1 very, very soon.
Is there
a weekly Is the Slack the best way
to get engaged with the community? Do you
have weekly calls, office hours, anything like that
that people can also get help with if
they do want to start making their own
integrations?
Yes.
So we have the Slack
where we are, where the Keptn Core team
and the Keptn community is online every day.
Then we have the Keptn developer calls every
Thursday
on
5PM
Central European Time.
So the next one is tomorrow.
Then we have also the Captain User Groups.
We run this monthly
and these are more sharing use cases
as I briefly described.
Had last time we had Adrian
from Keptn sharing his story around Litmus testing
and the chaos testing. We also had Sumit
from Intuit sharing already his story on integrating
different performance tests and then Keptn evaluations.
So we have different formats but for like
fast
response times around development,
I think best is to join the Keptn
Slack and also joining us on the Keptn
developer calls every Thursday.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, everyone should install Keptn, improve their
continuous delivery, take advantage of quality gates and
remediation and build your own integrations.
Join the Slack and join the developer calls.
Jorgen, thank you. That was really great to
see that from start to finish. I'm so
glad we came back for part two I
Thank you. Even though I broke it I'm
glad we got through there we've everything working
I'm really happy with that so
have a great day thank you again for
joining me and I hopefully speak to you
again soon.
Thank you David, have fun. Thanks.
Bye.